do you think an ai system will win a
nobel prize in this century what do you
think
does that make you sad if i can digress
and put in a plug for my next book yes
it has a chapter saying why nobel prizes
do more harm than good yes so
on a quite separate subject i think uh
nobel prize is too relatively damaged to
the perception of the way science is
done of course if you ask who or what
deserves the credit for any scientific
discovery it may be often someone has an
idea
a team of people who work a big
experiment etc um and of course
it's the quality of the equipment
which is um crucial and certainly in the
subjects i do in astronomy um the
huge advantages we've had uh come not
from us being more intelligent than
aristotle was but through us having far
far better
data
from powerful telescopes on the ground
in space and also incidentally
we benefit hugely in astronomy
from
computer simulations because
if you are
a subatomic physicist then of course you
crash together the particles in the big
accelerator like the one at cern and see
what happens but um i can't crash
together two galaxies or two stars and
see what happens but in the virtual
world of a computer
one can
do simulations like that and the power
of computers is such that these
simulations uh can
yield
a phenomena and insights which we
wouldn't have guessed beforehand and the
way we can
feel we're making progress and trying to
understand some of these phenomena why
galaxies have the size and shape they do
and all that is because we can do
simulations um tweaking different
initial conditions and seeing which
gives the best fit to what we actually
observe and so that's
a way in which we've made progress
in using uh computers and incidentally
we also now need them to analyze data
because one thinks of astronomy has been
traditionally rather data poor subjects
but the european satellite called gaia
has just put on line the um
speeds and colors and properties of
nearly two billion stars in the milky
way
and which you can do fantastic analyses
of and that of course could not be done
at all without just the number of
crunchy capacitors computers
you